hallo herr kubicki wenn man sich das so
anschaue dann könnten sie sich doch
heute hier und jetzt bei bild live
festlegen das ist eine ampelkoalition
nicht geben kann mit der fdp
zunächst einmal sollten sie die menschen
am morgen nicht erschrecken mit diesem
gruselkabinett dass er sich dadurch
auszeichnet hätten über sachsen das
einzige frau beteiligt ist aber
natürlich davon wir haben noch zwölf
tage aber ich bin auch eine bundestags-
vizepräsident auch wenn ich daran
arbeitet dass die fdp stärkste fraktion
werden wir den bundestagspräsidenten
stellen aber die an zwölf tagen bis zur
wahl darunter fdp vorsitzender und vize
stellvertretende bundestagspräsident ich
wollte sie nicht zu mehr machen als sie
ohnehin schon sind herr kubicki keine
sorge herzlichen dank wie gesagt ich
habe jetzt alle um möglichst große mehr
ich kann nur wieder sagen die starker
die freien demokraten werden desto
größer ist die wahrscheinlichkeit einer
vernünftigen einer pragmatischen politik
die da sehe ich unser land aus dem
dämmerschlaf daraus wird und wieder nach
vorne bringen alles weitere werden wir
nach der wahl sehen ich habe das schon
immer wieder erklärt ich gehe nach wie
vor davon aus dass eine chance besteht
dass armin laschet eine jamaika
koalition zustande bringt
selbstverständlich werden wir als freie
demokraten auch andere einlage für olaf
scholz folgen was denn sonst wir sind ja
demokratische parteien aber nach wie vor
gilt es gibt doch sehr hohe hürden für
eine position die zu überwinden wir
momentan schwer fällt denn daran zu
glauben ich kann mir schwer vorstellen
dass sozialdemokraten und grünen auch
ihre stände verzichten wollen ich kann
definitiv ausschließen für die freien
demokraten dass sie uns an areva
beteiligen die in ihrem programm
steuererhöhungen lassen sie uns mal noch
einmal auf das auf keinen fall kabinetts
das sagen sie eben gerade gruselkabinett
genannte kubicki was hätten sie denn
welche positionen finden sie da denn
besonders schlimm
ja eigentlich alle also heiko maas hat
sich als völlig untauglich erwiesen für
jedes regierungsamt saskia esken macht
schon durch ihre ausstrahlung deutlich
das ist kein zu kurz kam jetzt sein
könnten karen krüger katja mit 29 30
semester riesen da sind bisher kein
studium absolvierte das qualifizieren
die übrigen zu minister rollt mit ihnen
schließlich sehr der wäre nach meiner
auffassung tatsächlich auch
regierungstauglich karl lauterbach gott
bewahre uns davor ist
gesundheitsminister wird das werde ich
vor schluss einer fortsetzung der
politik von ihren spass nach wie vor das
entscheidende zweite auch die
sozialdemokratie zum schluss allein aber
ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass wir
von ihr genannten personen fielen an
kabinetts wiederfinden würden ich glaube
und auf stolze jetzt auch wie ich vor
diesem von dieser kam jetzt besetzung
wirklich angst haben gestern ein
bisschen beziehungsweise heute ein
bisschen bedauert hier und wollen in
keinen honig um den bart schmieren aber
dass christian lindner bei materiell
nicht dabei war das hätte passieren
können wenn er sich selber auch zum oder
die parteien zum kanzlerkandidaten
erklärt hätten so die grünen das ja auch
gemacht hat kann ja jeder machen guido
westerwelle hat es auch schon mal 2002
warum haben sie sich nicht getraut ja
weil klar war dass wir den nächsten
kanzler nicht stellen werden wegen der
größenordnung das war übrigens auch für
die grünen klagen weil es jetzt ist das
klar sonst könnte der ssb ja auch
teilnehmen binäre und seinen
abgeordneten der kandidiert zum
kanzlerkandidaten ausrufen weil ich
verstehe auch nicht warum die sender
nicht darauf reagieren dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist an der werburg
kanzlerin wird gegen null tendiert
deshalb hat sich eigentlich an einem
solchen trainer duell nichts mehr zu
suchen wenn man sollte darauf reagieren
dass die chancen für armin laschet und
olaf scholz in etwa gleich verteilt sind
nach wie vor die beiden sollten
miteinander ringen um die frage wer
führt das land aber nicht nur in der
werbung und wir schon gar nicht wie
gesagt jawoll nicht ganz an die stelle
obwohl christian lindner ich finde das
ein besserer kanzler als die drei
kandidaten die momentan da sind
herr kubicki armin laschet will jetzt
aufholen er will jetzt die trendwende
schaffen nun höre ich aus ihrer partei
das durchaus die sorge besteht dass er
das vielleicht wenn er das schafft ist
auf ihre kosten schafft haben sie angst
wenn sie wünschen armin laschet ja ein
wahlsieg sie wollen ja eine schwarz
gelbe koalition aber haben sie angst
dass die fdp dann vielleicht darunter
leiden könnte
nein diese angst habe ich nicht die
union muss schon für sich selbst sorgen
die geherin und bilder die uns
unterstützen wollen die freien
demokraten wollen eine vernünftige
politik am liebsten den undertaker
konstellation die wir immer noch
versuchen herzustellen wenn nicht wollen
unsere wiederum will jedenfalls dass die
politik der deutschlands 50 vernünftig
sein wird also noch einmal ich habe
keine angst vor den großen oder die eine
erklärung der union kassel gestern zu
recht gesagt wir haben vernünftige
politik will muss jetzt nicht mehr auf
die union dessen der kann auf die freien
demokraten setzen ich bin sicher wir
werden noch zum beitrag zu legen und die
union täte gut daran sich darum zu
kümmern dass hier auch stärker wird ja
nur sonst nur so schaffen wir eine
jamaika konstellation ansonsten werden
wir sehen was die wiederum bilder am tag
ins labor und rot-grün herr kubicki wir
hier diskutiert kann man das
mitte-links-bündnis nennen so wie es
jetzt in den öffentlich-rechtlichen
gefallen ist
ja das ist
natur und man kann sagen dass man lena
ich glaube nicht dass rot grün rot eine
eine mitte links regierung wäre das wäre
allerdings verschiebung innerhalb
deutschlands es wäre eine linke
koalition kann die mitte links koalition
noch einmal diese geografischen
einschätzungen sind nicht das was die
menschen wirklich interessiert sie
wollen wissen können sich an wohlstand
erhalten behalten sie ihre arbeitsplätze
werden wir mit logischer innovationen im
klimawandel sich kümmern wir uns
wirklich mehr um die schulen und legen
sich darüber das sind die themen die
konstellationen wer mit wem das ergibt
sich nach der wahl wir wollten uns hier
nicht gegenseitig ins wort folgen sowie
im trial sorry nochmal betriebsklima
jacobi mal realistisch betrachtet was
glauben sie können sie wirklich dann von
ihren forderungen am ende egal die
grünen werden auf jeden fall in einer
neuen regierung davon muss man ausgehen
dabei sein wenn sie auch dabei etwas
werden sie tatsächlich aufgeben müssen
das spannende ist ja dass man
verhandlungen nicht bedient wird er
fragen was gibt man auf sondern mit der
frage was jetzt mal durch es gibt rote
linien für uns das wissen alle
beteiligten die rote linie ist keine
steuererhöhung die rote linie ist kein
aufweichen der schuldenbremse und eine
weitere rote linie ist eine möglichst
schnelle rückkehr zu grundrechtlichen
normalität in der pandemie und darüber
hinaus das dänische modell ist etwas was
ich persönlich sehr stark favorisiere
aber noch einmal in den
wahrscheinlichsten konstellation in
jamaika oder ampel werden jedenfalls
grüne und freie demokraten
freidemokraten und grüne vertreten sein
ich kann nur sagen ich habe 2017 bei
verhandlungen mit den grünen in
schleswig holstein mit robert habeck
wirklich gar nicht schlechten sondern
gute erfahrungen gemacht weil wir alle
respektiert haben dass wir vom anderen
nicht erwarten dass endlich leisten kann
das ist eine basis für gespräche und für
verständigung wie gesagt alles weitere
sieht man am ende eines solchen tages
und nicht am anfang herr kubicki sie
haben aber jetzt klare rote linien
aufgezeigt und eine dieser roten linien
ist die korona politik die rückkehr zur
normalität und jetzt stellen wir uns
doch mal vor dass karl lauterbach der
mit abstand bekannteste
gesundheitspolitiker der republik und
auch der spd nun doch
gesundheitsminister wird können sie sich
das vorstellen oder ist karl lauterbach
für sie auch eine rote linie
karl lauterbach ist keine routine
sondern kalotte was karl lauterbach und
er ist auch den deutschen insgesamt
schwester mittel noch einmal wir werden
ja wenn wir koalitionsverhandlungen
führen zunächst und zum inhalt
unterhalten was ist die grundlage einer
regierungs möglichkeit der nächsten vier
jahre dann wird man sich über die frau
unterhalten wer wird welches ressort
besetzen und damit man sich anschließend
über die frage unterhalten darf man als
partei mit reden bei der frage wie
andere parteien ihre ressourcen zwei
sätzen noch einmal ich glaube nicht dass
keiner auf dem zettel von olaf scholz
ist und der rest ist wie gesagt
[Musik]